we hit the road
and some forks in it i'm falling for you
okay you're very courageous but
wound up in the shallow
this is your the bachelor presents
listen to your heart episode 5 recap
grab your glasses
it's time for roses and roses
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys
[Music]
hi everybody lauren zema
and we are far from the shallow but we
are also in it we're singing about it
what's happening with these
relationships hi
everybody coming in with another quick
vlog to let you know about another audio
issue we have this episode
it's a small one but i bought an ice
machine off of amazon that sits on the
counter
and makes ice because i drink a lot of
iced coffee and sometimes i like ice in
my wine
so anyway if you're hearing a noise
that's ice being made
or you know a ghost yeah okay bye you
guys we went to vegas and what happened
there
didn't stay there it went everywhere all
through us our emotions our
tears and our screams and singing we're
here
what did you guys think of this episode
let me know in the comments below
i loved it i have a lot to say about it
and i have a new rose to say it with yes
today we are trying andrew murray
vineyards
esperanza jose i don't know if i'm
saying that first would correctly
esperanz
i don't know but you know what this is a
vineyard again
here in california trying to support
and so here we go oh i gotta open it
[Music]
that's light that's fruity that's
delicious here we go it's gonna be a
good one you guys
[Music]
let's really get to it jc is watching
this and he's thinking god she's talking
so long
we are going to have so much to deal
with i can i see him laughing but also
he's
nervous laughter we're back at the
mansion and chris harrison comes in
good morning guys and he promises more
romantic dates more romantic dates
great we needed it one fault of
listening to your heart has been
you know some pretty low budge moments
wow how much do we make
and we know that but they do have high
budge talent
the problem with moving forward right
now is we can't do it here in los
angeles
so what are we gonna do things get
bigger where are we gonna go
things get better what will the dates be
we're
headed to vegas
[Music]
pack your bags we're heading to vegas
here's the thing i'm in the minority on
this and i acknowledge that
so many people love vegas i don't mean
to hate on vegas it's just not my place
you know not known for the wine there's
no ocean
how could i get in the sailboat none of
the things i love available in vegas
okay
but i get it because performances
because the big shows
the lights the glitz the glamour i do
love that the rat pack played there so
much i'm a big
sinatra fan i digress again okay
we have tour buses oh and we're gonna
get tour buses and i thought this was
truly very cool
uh each couple gets their own each
general
and the tour buses look good like these
are good buses they're not on some
greyhound situation definitely an
upgrade from the bunk
room they were all living in at the
mansion you know we got a mansion with a
freaking polo field in the back and
these guys are in a bunk bedroom
okay
if you can hear that that's the ghost
ice ghost dice
but i do like icing my wine so i can't
be such a hypocrite because i'm the one
drinking all the ice i like iced coffee
i like ice and my wine i know i just
said drinking ice and you can't do that
but you you know what i'm saying it's in
my drinks
i put icing red wine sometimes stop it
okay jc is not laughing anymore
and i'm here
[Applause]
[Music]
oh god we have a bedroom
this is cute oh and
and and they're not just moving out of
the bunk beds
they're sharing beds for the first time
on these buses
okay couples by the way quick vibe check
what's happening with natasha and ryan
what did you guys think of their romance
at this point because i have to say
i'm not feeling like the intimacy there
even when they're touching each other
there's something about it and i'm just
purely judging it on like my sense of it
it seems forced it just does let me know
in the comments below so they're gonna
go from la
to vegas and i will say that's like a
four or five hour drive
and you know when you really get to know
somebody
on a road trip i love a road trip i do
not too long of one not one where you
know everything starts to smell
but where you can spend some time in the
car and really have talks with people
and get to know everybody
i stand it i support it and also the
beds okay hook up
people and maybe the road trips will
help us answer questions because matt
doesn't know if he's falling for rudy
i'm still just a little hesitant to say
that i'm falling for her he's like i
might be
even though i might be or maybe i'm not
i don't know
it's confusing i just don't know and i
would say matt
if you don't know
it's probably a no
this is a rule of thumb everybody i'm
not saying that you should know about
someone after the first date
to be honest i'm not a believer in the
love at first sight thing but i do think
by a certain point
especially by now it's there it's not
you know
and matt knows i think do you think matt
knows
i just think matt doesn't want to say
what deep down
he knows so they're all getting to vegas
and
don't drink every time they all cheer
for each other's arrivals
i didn't get it everybody knew they were
all going to vegas then they keep
walking in the door and they're like
oh my god natasha
i told you i told you it's been four
hours you guys
and you were all probably caravanning
there so i don't know what's the concern
wait did you guys have fun now they talk
about what they did on the buses
they're like we snuggled these snuggles
that's so nice oh we took pictures we
did lots of polaroid pictures
nobody hooked up can i get a hookup
it's just it's been a while like i need
more making out i need more sexuality
i need more intimacy i want to see it oh
that is a difference on the show i feel
if we were on the bachelor or something
by this point it would be like making
out at every turn
i'm not saying it here i'm very grateful
to be out in the middle of
wherever the hell we are i guess not
everybody's making it to vegas i don't
think that we were
ready for vegas yet rudy and matt have
gone off the grid i suppose seemingly to
put a spotlight on
where their connection's at and you guys
everyone
all the babes instead of vegas
which was already down on the list for
me
i wrote down they are staying somewhere
that looks like
a murder room a murder room
i mean what is that bedroom where are we
what definitely ghosts in there right
rudy and matt come with love and light
that's all i can advise you
okay where the freak were you but they
make it to vegas and everybody keeps
having these conversations
is what's happening in vegas going to
stay in vegas
well brie and chris are very into each
other we know that they're in love they
have this emotional conversation that
honestly gave me goosebumps and
borderline brought me to tears they
talked about wanting to be there for
each other it's been a
real relief to find you being everything
that the other person needs and deserves
i want to be there for him and i want to
be everything that he needs and deserves
and then there's rudy and matt and matt
says he wakes up thinking about her but
i wake up every day and i'm thinking
about her but still doesn't know if he's
there
i don't know if i'm like there and i
wrote down where
he doesn't know if he's in love he
doesn't know if he's in vegas
did something possess him in the ghost
room
let me know in the comments below i can
see myself
falling for him rudy on the other hand
is saying that she could say that she
loves him
oh god i literally just almost screamed
like oh my god i love you
we know where this is heading
[Music]
i don't think matt doesn't care about
rudy i just think it's good
not great i mean we could all make
things work with a lot of people the
question is do you want to
[Music]
that's absolutely insane we are
continuing to assess where everyone's at
jamie and trevor i wasn't sure about but
they go on this
ice skating date which seems strange for
vegas
of all things to do there trevor tells
her that he doesn't say i love you
lightly which i respect
i take that word more seriously and
sacred than any other word
and that's making me think he's not
going to say he loves her
but then things took a turn they say
they're proud of
each other really proud of you
[Music]
how did you cry no
and i thought that's nice that's a
genuine sentiment and then they cry
together
oh and i liked that oh and then they say
they are falling in love with each other
i
am falling in love with you
[Music]
i'm falling in love with you too
and you know what cheers to that being a
cop-out that's what it was
i've said this before but nobody says
that
wow page two matt and rudy it's you
it's both of you now rudy and matt are
gonna go on another date
and we know that she wants to say she's
falling in love with him i just need to
tell matt but i'm falling in love with
him so we're going
and i'm hearing music and i'm thinking
what's the perfect music
to tell someone that you fall in love
with them too and the song
is shaggy
[Music]
it wasn't me it's so wild dude shaggy
up there on stage the song is about
cheating
why is this the song i guess because
they had shaggy books for the day oh my
love to shaggy i've interviewed him a
couple times very nice human being and
you know what that song's a jam
it wasn't me and matt's like it isn't me
matt's actually gonna sing along and he
looks a little bit nervous this song
might not be his style and now rudy is
going to
sing to matt and by that i mean share
her emotions like you've legitimately
been my rock
and matt still looks nervous
so rudy does it but yeah i
you know what she drops it she tells
matt
she's falling in love with him i'm
falling for you okay
i'm falling for you and don't drink
during
all the silence
i would regret like not telling you that
[Music]
so what will he say what's he gonna say
predict his response
andy says and i quote you're very
courageous
for speaking your truth and i appreciate
you doing that
you're very courageous
for speaking your truth
and i appreciate you doing that
so so
oh you guys this so really set me
i mean that's one of those where i was
typing it out and i wrote dot dot dot
so rudy doesn't know what to do
rudy's holding her nose is rudy
breathing
rudy's definitely crying rudy
pour one out for rudy and by pour one
out i mean into your mouth okay
have i never said that before now i
appreciate that matt
didn't lie to her but i also think that
matt
should have told her where he was at
before she
just put herself out there what's the
point if if you're not there
but we're still checking in with all the
couples so now we're gonna go to natasha
and ryan and again i'm just not feeling
things when i'm here
again weird for vegas a construction
date i thought chris harrison promised
really
glamorous top level dates more romantic
dates at this point i didn't really know
what had happened with rudy and matt i
guess they stayed
like rudy says she's confused i wish i
could just read
what is going on at the top of his
little noggin
and i wanted to say if it's not clear
get out of here you don't want to be in
a relationship with someone
where you're wondering how they feel
about you all that's going to do is
attack your own self-confidence
make you feel insecure and make you
wonder if you are enough and the answer
is you are enough
you just might not be the right fit for
them so i wanted rudy to leave
just for her but then selfishly for me
i wanted them to stay because they're
gonna sing
shallow they're singing
what do shallow need more oh but you
guys i was so worried for rudy this
episode don't drink
every time rudy said something naive
i just hope he can get there with me i
just want that chance to continue to
grow
our relationship i wish matt would see
how great together we are
she said and i quote i want to fight for
him
and i hope he lets me i want to fight
for him and
i just hope he lets me rudy you
shouldn't fight for someone
to have feelings for you life's going to
throw stuff at you
it's going to get hard you're going to
have to fight all the outside forces
you don't want to have to fight for the
feelings this hotel is where lady gaga
performs her more intimate shows
so our couples have a lot to live up to
here tonight it's the performances
so ari and lauren are here pat monahan
and ooh the lead singer of train is here
i was a big fan now every word to drop
some jupiter oh
and ashley simpson
[Music]
so first chris and brie go and even
though they cried over getting this
song i wasn't that moved by the
performance until they kicked it up a
notch bam
old school amber lagasse reference bam
bam that's a little band right there
i don't know why that came out
okay i'll tell you guys because i've
been re-watching episodes of the office
while i'm quarantined just to be like
comforting myself in sex in the city
because i find both nostalgic and
amusing and thought-provoking and
anyway there's an episode of the office
i believe it's season two the casino
episode where
michael's on the phone with jan and he
says bam from lagasse
that's where we're at okay
that show holds up what shows are you
guys watching in the quarantine
let me know in the comments below and
rudy is backstage
and again she's naive she says i want to
find love but i'm not going to force it
on anyone i want to find love
but i'm not going to force it on anyone
rudy you
actually can't
now jamie and trevor are performing and
i am
loving this jamie i had critiqued jamie
because she was always crying
she was always freaking out she was
always needing to be lifted up
and now don't drink for every great
thing jamie says she is confident
i'm a rock star tonight that's right she
is strong this is my concert
they don't get to see me she is ready to
flip the script and be the rock for
trevor it's crazy i'm nervous and she's
my rock
i'm feeling myself let's go
great and and and
we hadn't had one of these in a while
jamie with her occasional introspective
bombs
she says that she has realized that
often
when she was afraid before something
that thing turned out to be great
every time i've been so scared has been
right before something's so good push
yourselves everybody
doing things you're afraid of makes you
grow
i found a girl
[Music]
and natasha and ryan are performing and
they're doing ed
sheeran and beyonce that felt big
i felt huge we are still kids
[Music]
and they fell short you know what i'm
saying it was awkward what was the
microphone work
don't drink for all the awkward
microphone work
he hands ryan's the microphone we were
all like why is he got the mic and he's
trying to play and
what was happening she was like let me
put it on a stand here
no wait i'm gonna hold it in my hand
here no wait you hold it in your hand
there oh you have a guitar i'm gonna
take it over here
put it right here by your face that's
that seems good everybody
no now you hold it sing into it it's
gonna be good
i don't does it fit is this good
you're perfect to me
it was rough
[Music]
oh god why do we have those okay
and what is that it's a candle holder i
don't even know how this works oh it
does okay sure
sorry i don't know why you had to play
guitar man i thought maybe you guys were
gonna have an intimate moment
oh and pat monahan from train is calling
it out he's saying those drops of
jupiter
weren't in your hair they were
everywhere and what were you doing
how do you guys feel do you think that
you nailed it oh but natasha is crying
and she's saying she had something
special planned we had something very
special planned for this performance and
she's sorry if she did something to
screw it up i'm sorry if i did anything
to screw it up
so wait did she or not what was the
special plan
i feel like bill hater in that snl skit
when he's her herb
[Music]
yeah answer me i love that skit
this is not plugged into a single thing
but people are saying what i've been
saying that they don't seem to have a
genuine connection
there was two different ideas and it
really wasn't coming
together so natasha explains
i guess she's saying the wrong part of
the song i sang the wrong part of the
song
which led us to completely disconnect on
stage
but i think ryan's the wrong person for
her
it wasn't perfect next couple singing
shallow by lady gaga and bradley cooper
let's welcome rudy and matt and now
the moment we've been waiting for put on
your sunday shoes
get your tickets grab your glasses
it's shallow tell me something
now so matt and rudy are singing and
they
are just nailing it aren't they aren't
they
we're gonna need a little more wine for
this cause we've gotta celebrate
[Music]
have a sip for that little wink rudy
dude and pour one out for matt's smile
and everybody don't drink
for when rooney did the lady gaga
[Music]
let's get a review from mother monster
herself talented brilliant
incredible amazing show-stopping
spectacular
matt and rudy are so happy they're so
into each other again
and i wrote down that performance was a
band-aid
rudy even said and i quote i just feel
he's falling for me and now i feel like
he's falling for me too
rudy you're feeling it he's not saying
it
okay these are talent crushes
because every time they perform together
they're super into each other
have you ever had a talent crush now if
you don't know what it is let me explain
a talent crush is when things wouldn't
really work with you and another person
but you love their talent and you vibe
on similar passions and so you have a
talent crush
my talent crush is jean-marc
valle and you might not know who that is
who would
he is the director slash producer of big
little lies and i love that show
and it spoke to me and i love the
soundtrack i love the cinematography
and i've interviewed him a couple of
times we're not dating
do you see what i'm saying but we raise
the glass to big little lies i love that
show we didn't talk about big little
lies enough on roses and rose season two
did you like season two of big little
eyes let me know in the comments below
it's the rose ceremony
jamie and trevor so jamie and trevor get
a rose and that tracks
rudy and matt and even though matt and
rudy seem doomed they get a rose and
that tracks
and the natasha and ryan are standing
against chris and brie
and natasha and ryan had to be thinking
oh we're going home
bree and chris and they did and i was
shocked because they said they can't
wait to see what the future holds
they're going to continue their
relationship so wait are they still
together
now i'm probably gonna have to do a vlog
updating on whether or not they are
together because i'm sure that on monday
night they will possibly address that on
social media
maybe i was wrong maybe they're still
together maybe they had a genuine
connection i don't know
they have not posted to let us know if
they're together
and next week is the finale coming up
next week
and they are going to nashville and that
makes sense because music and we are
going to get a fantasy sweden and
wait is matt saying he's madly in love
with
rudy like i'm madly in love with her
am i totally wrong with my relationship
advice oh no she's crying i don't think
so okay
but is something going wrong with chris
and bree
my heart doesn't lie to me there's
something wrong
[Music]
that's mariah carey note for you ball
said oh
what day of quarantine are we on 57 93
682 let me know in the comments below
okay
this is wild what are we hello how are
you guys doing
my name is jim you guys i never talk
about those last few minutes of the show
they're often like some kind of funny
throwaway thing but i just couldn't
believe this
i legit when matt and rudy entered that
place they stayed at i was like that
place is on
it and what we get in the last few
minutes is more footage from this
strange little side trip they took
and the owner of the hotel telling them
that it's
haunted is it haunted any jews
is it jim jim
come on now i cannot confirm or deny
you knew we all knew
there's more of you here now what i
loved and what actually made me want to
go check out this place
is the owner's mentality he said and i
quote
if you feel a ghost let it spoon with
you
if you hear a noise just kind of scoot
over and let them spoon with you they'll
leave you alone
love and light everybody love and light
i love you guys
thank you so much as always for watching
roses and rose you can find me on
twitter
instagram and tick tock where some weird
and wonderful stuff is happening
and if you want a message for me you can
get that on the app cameo
thank you again for being here i hope
everybody is staying safe staying well
and
supporting each other and i'll see you
next week for the big finale of
listen to your heart bye
[Music]
oh broke that mother trucker maybe that
was going to happen it's fine it's fake
and next week is the finale and
next week is the finale and last week is
the
[Music]
finale
[Applause]
[Music]